hello everyone like the game from my
previous video this one was also played
in 1969 obviously in 1969 featured some
crazy chess games the game was played in
Italian the capital city of Estonia it
was played between the first who's Becky
stannie
chess master imagine a Mookie Dean of
he's playing against Lithuania chess
coach chess arbiter Dean Toto's jurgis
Plunkett not really sure how to
pronounce what winning names and the
world for game that derives from the
rural opus it has a completely
unexpected turn of events it's quite a
crazy game and it really took me a while
to understand what was going on I'm
really interested to hear if if you can
understand the position when you see it
so let's see the game mister Mookie Dino
has the white piece and he plays efore
we have E 5 Knight to f3 and Knight to
c6 and Bishop to b5 the rule opus we
have Bishop to c5 white castles and now
Knights the d4 offering offering this
ePHI pawn but this is this is never good
for good for white this is a pretty
pretty standard gambit but white
declines this with Knight captures on d4
we have Bishop captures on d4 and now c3
Bishop to b6 and d4 so a pretty standard
position c6 kicking the bishop boy from
b5 bishop to a4 we have d6
night to a3 Knight to f6 and Bishop to
g5 pinning the knight h6 Bishop captures
on f6 Queen captures on f6 and d5 now we
have Bishop to d7 Knight to c4 Bishop to
c7 and he doesn't want to allow this
dark square bishop to be exchanged for
the night D captures on c6 d captures on
c6 and Queen to d3 preparing together a
one rock into the game black castles
here and we have rook a to d1
rook F to d8 was played night to e3 and
now Queen to f4
we have B for a five black wants to open
up the a file with either a captures on
b4 or B captors on a5 but why it
definitely does not want to let this
happen he plays b5 and well with this b5
move white is starting a devious plan
and well he already had to see the final
position when he played this b5 move
otherwise I don't think he would play it
because blacks response would force him
to calculate all that way so he does he
plays b5 and we have D 5 now threatening
D captures on e4 also opening up a
discovery from this rope to the Queen
after the bishop moves but what why
doesn't mind we have B captures on c6
and now with an attack on the bishop but
there is an in-between move D captures
on e4 black is attacking the White Queen
and e3 and this is the position white
had to see when he played b5 and well
I'm not gonna ask you to find the the
best move here I'm just gonna show you
the move the move white played as Queen
captures on d7 offering offering his
Queen and this is the position I would
like you to really really look at and
try to figure out what is the idea
behind the Queen sacrifice can black
capture the Queen I mean he definitely
has to or he can just resign the game I
mean but what's the idea behind the
sacrifice if if the Queen sacrifice is
accepted worldwide recapture with the
pawn would he recapture with the rook
and what happens then so it's very
interesting I do urge you to pause the
video and and really try try to
understand this
I'll give it a couple of seconds okay
for those of you who did manage to solve
this I really congratulate you it's it's
quite a position to solve and for those
of you who just want to just want to
enjoy the show
rook captures and d7 was played and
white recaptured with rook captures and
d7
and in this position mr. Gein taught us
resigned the game because if you look at
the position now and I'm pretty sure
this is the position white saw when he
pushed b5 black is completely lost here
he can't save this bishop the bishop on
c7 is is attacked and there is nothing
black can do if Bishop to b6 is played
the Knights the d5 comes put a temple on
the Queen and f4 also attacking the
bishop this bishop is now lost somewhat
better defense would be maybe maybe
Bishop to d8 but after c7 Black is
losing this bishop if you try to save it
with a move like Bishop to f6 you get
rook to be one and there is no defense
against rook to b8 and if you don't play
Bishop f6 well you simply have to give
up the bishop and after rook captures
you have two rooks for black Queen and
well you do have the knight and the
bishop for the rook again are completely
winning position for white and lastly
after rook after 77 you could play
something like rook to a7 but this
doesn't help after night that Knight to
d5 this also comes with a temp on the
Queen on f4 you're losing the bishop and
even after even after a move like Queen
to g5 you just captured a bishop if
black tries to create some cons reply
would perhaps III you just capture it as
captures only three Queen captures would
check King to h1 and after Queen e2 with
a temple on the rook trying to cause
some turbulence here simply Bishop to b5
this is attacking the Queen I need to
also defends the rook on f1 all White's
pieces are ideally placed this is this
is beautiful for white for example Queen
captures an a2 now rock to d8 check King
to h7 Bishop comes to d3 with check g6
and after night to b5 what a temple on
the rook the C pawn is well I'm going to
become a queen very soon and the whites
pieces are so ideally placed this is
beaut
this rook is protecting the bishop on d3
the bishop on d3 is protecting the
knight on d5 and also the rook on f1 and
the knight on b5 is attacking the rook
and a7 also guarding c7 so c7 is coming
already and protected and while c8 is
protected by the rook so this is quite
beautiful but black didn't want to allow
any of this and after rook after 77 he
resigned the game so definitely a
beautiful idea and a beautiful game but
the first was Beckett a Pakistani chess
master
I'm imagine Mookie Dean of and well this
game came I mean this whole idea came so
unexpected to me that I'm forced to name
this video chess sorcery number 5 as
well as the previous 4 chess sorcerer is
the Queen sacrifices and the entire
games were quite fascinating so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoy it
and one more thing this is the only
photo I could find of mr. Mookie Deneuve
as it's a pretty bad photo so if any of
you are able to find another photo of
him some some photo of maybe a better
quality I would appreciate it if you
just send it to me you know either shirt
with a link in the comments or anyway it
would be fine so yeah that's it I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here I
think of for watching and I will see you
soon